they say black don't crack but what
agent don't reason hey then don't you
know
I love Rimes rhymes are the whites of
fright try to think of a real good
whites a fright are you a white guy all
the way are you all the way white it's
weird like something of dad would ask
I'm a dad shonali you look like you have
something else in you get some well I
did I did the 23andme and it was my mom
was born raised in England so it's 50%
English I'm standing on so your dinner
is Italian and so your first generation
American yes oh wow so you have the
Italian side yep love it now Italian is
actually considered Caucasian probably
which is weird because they're really
Brown yeah they are but it was defensive
your southern Italian yeah I'm southern
Italian mmm I'm all the way white yeah I
do have Native American but you know you
get a hat stop they used to think he was
when his name in the blingy fought was
the hybrid before it changed a big brown
and [ __ ] hybrid the hybrid and they
thought because he was like a big brown
was you're fighting me on that I thought
that's what you know they call a hybrid
he gave me the nickname big round and
they got so popular that there's AI love
change my name to big brown oh wow
but busy Brian they thought by the first
hybrid a lot of people thought he was
like a hybrid like they were like a bro
I'm mixed to I'm black and white and
bright I'm like no that's not what it
means I thought I'd [ __ ] physically
you know what was the meaning of a high
calling hybrid athletics right yeah high
because I was a big guy that moved like
a little day yeah nice and then that
blame Toyota hybrid that's so funny
I ain't got [ __ ] I don't why just
watching TV and you're like who gave you
the high bro foot the the UFC the
Ultimate Fighter producers oh really
yeah how would you do that I don't know
a lot about it if you said too long Oh
too long think of it seven seven years
bro um how long he been he was stand up
where's now five years oh I hit 40 it
was like I would watch him quietly
suffer just the [ __ ] stress of
fighting monsters how much better strand
of self you wanna never do there
anything ever people always ask me are
you nervous when you go on stage you
can't be no because for so long you walk
into an arena where the gravity store
really open because your peers or
because you gotta cops legs look at the
size of his [ __ ] legs cuz it peers
about you wait who's that that's that's
Mirko Cro Cop crazy-ass linear college
days I stopped I stopped watching all
this stuff he was a beast stop watching
all this stuff yeah but but stand up it
to me is just not you might not get any
more manly than Mirko Cro Cop mmm he was
like a special forces on the guy and
everything really yeah yeah it's just
he's as tough as he gets he's the
biggest baddest no I love about this
podcast is that you can go from singing
love songs and crying to journey and
then right and then a little bit of
racism mixing accidental racism by the
way said I know my people are
accidentally racist Ohio - we do believe
we are as Korean always on accident like
white people are the only race people
addresses as another race for Halloween
Halloween this year Brian
oh no cholo Rastafarian I don't know
black people don't do that we probably
know no a lifeguard or a ski instructor
ya know black ass be a white guy value
which would be awesome like you never
seem to go white yeah I will be a
beekeeper this year dawg yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]